hôm nay bắt quý tham tư, thang ninh rửa rất vật dụ khách,
nổ vệ khu vực sai gòn marina AFC,
không ký bên sống cho nên vụ nít,
khi nhiều gia đình bản chế vật dụ khách,
cùng nhau giọc chơi, chứ bản vật dụng đón ngon,
và qua những là cự đỏ sau bản,
những lụ cười hảo vực,
hảo nít được chanh lễ hộ dụng giản,
giữa lòng tình khố,
xa gòn marina AFC,
buông lình từ dị sản trong năm và được lịch vướng
chở thành một hảo tâm là chính xử lượng.
Này là nơi hộ tụng các đoàn đá khúc xa,
lịch trẻ thay chính,
nhà đồ tư,
bởi đầu tư và các hộ chức khúc sế,
không chỉ là một tông dình cáo tâm.
Nơi đây còn tư vụ quốc lệ ra,
bởi tông ra 1 vệ xong và tình dựng giọc,
nhiều vời đợi sọc của buộc này,
để tận vường cho đẹp thu hí lế hộ,
một cách khách biệt.
Để bí trọng sẽ không ảnh đi những là bíu đất là đẹp,
khoáng, mát,
an lình và đặc biệt là,
khi mà họ mắt đây là sẽ hiện gái,
nó không có kể ui giống như tuyệt vòng.
Lầna sẽ mắt tựa tân số,
khi họ phải tự giết đất là,
như theo dụng mình coi để đáo đi ra.
Thì mạnh đến đôi xuống,
và tắt mắt đầu tài sáng với hệ thường lế tọc hình tông dình.
Những người nạn nghiệp xử được trình chíu,
rợi lại công phía của người kiện đặc biệt.
Bồi lế thích địa bơi,
bầu khu khí với tất cả mọi người ở đây,
cùng với anh đàn và mạnh bằng phó hoa,
đều sức ấn tượng.
Mình hà bị mốt rồi.
Hãy hợp tỏ hoa đồ tiên được mạnh lên,
bởi các tình đào.
Thì ở đây, xảyết hợp tình vòng,
hả nên một màn trình dễn thú,
cũng cũng chỉ chỉ có hả bị dưới.
Mạnh lông công dễ hợp khi thảo hoa tắt sáng mùi,
dưới ra đình được các nhỏ đi cùng.
Các em cũng thích thú,
khi là đồ tiên trình dễn màn trình dễn thử,
hả nhạc, không?
Thì cũng mạnh là bên được về Việt Nam,
trong gì Plei.
Và được hợp ở đây,
dễ trình phía ríc,
nhưng khi các bạn bằng to qua ngoan mục quỡo,
và mình khả là bất ngờ mở cái không gà sức bất ngờ.
Mò có lên khi tại lại cửa phó nhà,
cũng như là cho mình có nhiều phía vế phủ các đại xúc lọc.
Đến tệnh phóng qua,
khu bực công biến và nhạc nước,
phủ thú đồng đạo người dân.
Saigon Narina, AFC,
không chỉ một tâm biển kết lộn tàn câu bị tài chính,
mà còn làm một tiểu tượng mời,
giữa không tăng đồ tiện không đừng phát triển.